-As I mentioned before,
Alex Rodriguez
is on the show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so glad he's here.
We actually had the chance
to work together recently.
We called a baseball game
together.
And it was a lot of fun.
But the teleprompter operator
was kind of a loose cannon.
He would put lines
into the teleprompter
that we had never seen before,
so we'd end up reading things
for the first time live on air.
It was a little nerve-racking,
but I think we handled it
all right.
We actually have a clip
of some of our highlights
from the broadcast.
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello!
And welcome to today's game.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
And if you're wondering,
yes, they're real.
-Yes, they are.
And I'm Alex Rodriguez.
And you can call me
little cutie.
Wait. Juicy Fruit booty.
Uh, Jimmy, can I be honest?
Uh, I have an idea.
What am I doing here?
And what baseball is?
Back to you, Cynthia. What?
-Well, Gonzalez
steps up to the plate.
He's hoping to raise
his batting average.
But me, I'm hoping to raise
my cholesterol, which is...
why I eat one hard-boiled egg
at breakfast,
one at lunch, one at dinner,
and one right before
making love.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, uh, baseball actually
reminds me a lot of making love.
-Oh, yeah? Why is that?
-It's slow, boring.
And you always leave early
to beat the traffic.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey. Just a --
Just a quick reminder
that tomorrow night at
the stadium is Rat Night.
Uh, the...
first 20,000 fans...
[ Laughs ]
...to arrive will get
a free, live rat.
For tickets to the game,
call our number at 212-WET-RAT,
extension 12.
[ Laughs ]
Ask for Lenny Kravitz.
No, not that Lenny Kravitz.
A different Lenny Kravitz.
Anyway, he's a good dude.
He'll hook you up with a rat.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Here's a fun fact.
I never used to shower
after games.
-Oh.
-I used to strip down in front
of my locker and lick myself.
Clean my little kitty cat.
And meow, meow.
Ish?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, what makes Taylor
such a good pitcher
is that he throws
a blinding fastball,
a wicked change-up,
smelly curveball,
super-horny splitter,
and a boozy daiquiri.
Oink-oink?
What does the hog say?
[ Laughter ]
-I was -- I was thinking
they should make a "Space Jam"
for baseball.
-Oh, yeah.
-I'll play Bugs Bunny
and say his famous catch phrase,
"Uh, how's it going, Docta?"
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
when I root for a team,
I like to say my favorite cheer.
"Oh, mama, Dalai Lama,
Charlie Sheen, Barack Obama.
Tickle me, I'll tickle you.
Seal my butt with Elmer's Glue."
-I actually won the MVP
in 2003, '05, and '07.
But he don't fool
by the rocks that I got.
I'm still Ally from the block.
Bazinga.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-We should --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We should do that more often.
-We should.